cancer is the most life-threatening
situation the children face asked the
neonatal period except for accidents at
the 1968 meeting of the American radium
society one aspect of pediatric cancer
is on the program for this reason and
also because the treatment of solid
tumors in children requires the joint
services of surgeon radio therapists and
chemo therapists and all three of these
disciplines are represented in our
membership
as a professional education extension
50th annual meeting the American radium
society presents childhood cancer
current outlet participants are dr.
louis murphy chairman of the department
of pediatrics at Memorial Hospital in
New York
dr. Lester w martin director of
pediatric surgery at the Children's
Hospital in Cincinnati Ohio dr. Melvin
theft radio therapists in chief at the
Children's Hospital in Boston and as
moderator dr. Lemuel Bowden associate
attending surgeon at Memorial Hospital
in New York City obviously in the time
allotted it would be impossible to
comment even briefly on every type of
solid malignant tumors childhood and we
have agreed to confine our remarks to
three of the most common ones namely
wilms tumor neuroblastoma and in Bryan
Arab DeMaio sarcoma the first case that
I'd like to present is that of a
nine-month-old baby boy who was noted
approximately one month before hospital
admission to have a slowly increasing
abdominal girth with some distension of
a superficial veins of the abdomen but
was not noted to have an abdominal mass
until the day prior to admission an
immediate IVP was secured and this
reveal the presence of a lesion of the
right kidney on the basis of this brief
history dr. Martin how would you go
about managing this case this particular
wilms tumor is an ideal candidate for
immediate object removal the origin of
the tumor from the North Pole the kidney
tend to displace illegal pedicle upward
somewhat and creates a bit more of a
difficult operating for foolish for the
surgeon a point to be late for a source
for abdominal opposed to this particular
child or ordinary as here in the
photograph we refer a transverse
abdominal incision extending from one
flying to the others providing generous
exposure and permitting early operation
of renal pedicle in the course of the
operation the location of the tumor was
in the kidney as a
more important to the surgeon than as
the size as seen in the next photograph
a particularly large tumor may be
removed with relative ease we feel that
during the course of the operation the
objectivity should be examined carefully
and the one shown in the next photograph
the tumor on the opposite side may be
particularly small and can be detected
only by kelvin examination of all
aspects of the objectivity bilateral
involvement can be expected in
approximately ten percent of the
patients with Rome tumor was here that
the operation is not complete until a
thorough Rachel stretch meal reps or
discussion has been carried out
occasionally the tumor spread to the
recent surgery or no prior to its spread
to the lungs or elsewhere in on early
case such as this one we have just the
tables the Deerfield architect that
there is any place for radiation start
the impossible you would also comment on
the possibility of finding positive
nodes of extra renal extension at the
time of surgical exploration and thereby
also in such an instance in need for
radiation perfect well in the younger
charl especially charlton to 13 months
of age with a good overall prognosis
when the tumor is well encapsulated and
was no evidence that breaking the castle
when there is no lymph node involvement
and when there is no local vascular
invasion it is not our policy to use
routine post-operative irradiation
however when any of these other things
are true when these things are positive
at a time of initial surgery all in the
older child when radiotherapy is use the
volume is carefully tailored to
encompass the tumor-bearing tissue and
minimize the radiation to normal growth
structures the dose is consistent with
both control of the tumor and adjusted
to the tolerance of normal tissues in
the growing child once mercy
in an early wilms tumor what places are
for chemotherapy I've commonly accepted
practice is to start a course of action
amaizing be on the day of operation many
centers then give repeated courses of
action amaizing be at intervals of six
weeks to two or three months for one
year in our institution the first two
doses of act gentamicin be are given
before operation together with two doses
of radiotherapy over the tumor following
operation the remaining three doses of
act in amaizing they are given and the
radiotherapy course continued refuses of
at gentamicin d are given at intervals
of two to three months for one to two
years of course the idea behind such
therapy is to prevent we hope the
possibility of metastasis if metastasis
however do occur in a Wilms tumor other
this a median invariably on completely
on published prognosis doctor must know
there are many children who have
received chemotherapy and radiotherapy
for metastatic tumor who have had
disappearance of these conditions and a
well as predacons and is any choice do
you think between the chemotherapy and
the radiation therapy management of such
metastatic lesions or do you think it's
entirely a combined our combined
endeavor I think that it should be a
combined endeavor and of course that the
lesions that may be excised surgically
if they're discreet I was gonna ask that
of dr. Martin in the case of a solitary
metaxa pulmonary metastases from
wellness too much do you think it's very
often that it is in fact solitary and
that there is a place then fall of
surgical approach and segmental excision
a lobectomy such a solitary investors in
answer to the first question I doubt
that any
them are solitary I suspect that most of
them are multiple we feels that the
initial metastatic we should be treated
by a combination of radiation plus
chemotherapy in the convalescence one
single nation will recur from this
course of treatment it was horrible
persist in spite of combined therapy in
an instance we do if I surgical removal
and in case another one should be co
later on we realize that we've had one
child that it has five different
recessions removing only a small amount
of running tissue with each particular
tumor and the child has now had five
over five years since the light
expression what the test each other
comment on the management of metastatic
films to our degree complete without the
mercy that's the first tag i am dr.
martin that the first attack would be a
combination of radiotherapy and
chemotherapy for the first evidence of
metastasis and certainly there are some
tools who do have solitaire regions that
have survived after excision I think the
only point to make is that one wonders
irradiate the lung fields from attackers
one includes the total volume of both
lungs both agencies and bases first case
being in a relatively early example of
wilms tumor probably carries a very good
prognosis with it unfortunately this is
not the case with all childhood tumors
and for the next case I'd like to
present that of a seven-month-old baby
girl who was found some two months
before admission to the hospital to have
likewise an enlarged in abdomen and was
noted to have an abdominal mass in the
left upper quadrant shortly before
admission at the same time as a mass in
the left groin was identified the small
mass in the left groin was removed of a
histologic study and proved to be
metastatic neuroblastoma and I BP
secured revealed mass distortion of the
left kidney position because of the
presence of a large super renal mass
with flaky calcification contained
furthermore a marrow aspiration in this
jar revealed the presence of extrinsic
cells consistent with metastatic
neuroblastoma in the marrow over the
skeletal survey showed no definite
evidence of bone destruction or in a
situation of this store thought the test
would you comment as to how you would
approach the problem there are beautiful
well in eternal under one year of age
because the distinctly better prognosis
is compared to the older child with
neuroblastoma even such evidence of
disseminated disease every attempt is
made to control the disease that is
encompassing and comfortable by
irradiation and it doses tolerable to
normal growing tissue therefore after
biopsy and possibly after surgical
removal of the super real primary be
that advocated radiation of the super
real salsa and the node bearing areas in
continuity with this are involved are
growing node in advanced cases in older
children when there is a juice bone
destruction by x-ray we would deliver
more modest painted doses of radiation
to the local sites the ious dr. Martin
Oh would you consider medias Treasury on
the primary coma above the above the
West kidney as a surgeon or would you
prefer possibly to ask your radiation
therapist colleague to give preliminary
radiation therapy before attacking me
surgically or would you attack the
primary tumor surgically at all in this
particular child with evidence of
meditate disease in the bone well we
would be less feel less urgent about
authors removal if we had a negative
bone marrow we would of course this
aggressively and go immediately and
remove the truth when a party for
merrily the discussion the members of
the team rushes and come to a decision
and I suspect that we would probably
remove the primary and then use combined
radiation image and variances and dr.
wrapping up the question of the
involvement on Mara has been
most of the minds of all of us in this
particular patient would you comment on
the significance of this and the
treatment of this chemotherapeutic Lee
if you feel this is what should be done
I'd like to reemphasize what dr. ted
says that the prognosis in such a
patient is brave but not hopeless
neuroblastoma invading bone marrow has
similarities to acute leukemia treatment
should be selected to eradicate the
extrinsic cells thereafter normal bone
marrow cells return neuroblastoma cells
can be suppressed within a few days by
the more vigorous chemotherapeutic
agents for example a full dose of
nitrogen mustards of course of action
amaizing day or high doses of strife
across women there may result
hyperuricemia temporary severe
thrombocytopenia and leukopenia to treat
with these agents the child needs to be
prepared with good hydration and our
pure in all to present hyperuricemia in
addition if reading develops platelet
concentrates for supportive management
may be required if leukopenia is severe
enough to lower the circulating
granulocytes counts to 1500 aspect
isolation to guard against infection may
be necessary and the normal bone marrow
should regenerate within two or three
weeks following with a maintenance
schedule of weekly alternating doses of
cyclocross med and vincristine can be
used if one is not able to give heroic
supportive therapy to such a patient the
ladder to drugs can be used as the
initial treatment and some good results
have been observed with them some kind
of chemotherapy certainly should be
given for probably two years the
catecholamine excretion in the urine as
well as careful physical examination and
serial bone marrow examinations are
helpful in determining activity of the
breast doma during the course of
treatment no and of course the matter
poetic depression affect the most of the
chemotherapeutic agents I think some
practitioners might rightly feel
the use of massive doses of any of the
chemotherapeutic drugs if it appeared
that the Mao had been largely replaced
by extrinsic tumor cells would you
comment on that do you think if that is
a conf indicating factor this is the
degree of Merrill replacement in network
well this theory certainly justified and
we all all share it however these you
know blastoma cells must be removed from
the ball now before there can be a
remission and return of normal elements
so it takes a good deal clinical
judgment in determining how much of an
agent a given patient be tolerated it
has something to do with a mal reserved
and given child one comment I think the
certainly should be made with regard to
neuroblastoma is the fact that an
occasional instances there will be of
course spontaneous regression of the
tumor that is currently not completely
understood and for that reason to i
think that are totally hopeless
prognosis should not be given even in an
advanced case such as we've just seen
now I'd like to go on to one third case
if I made this is that of a ten-year-old
boy two three weeks prior to admission
to the hospital we've noted by his
mother to have a painless mass in the
right arm fixed to the ball one all
seemingly fixed to the bone and just
distal to the elbow he was seen by his
local physician and partly referred to
the hospital in the suspicion that this
must be a malignant tumor at the time of
admission this mass was noted to be
fairly good size 5 by 3 cm per mil two
people trading mass and at the same time
two or three definitely enlarged lymph
nodes were identified in the axilla of
that side of assuming as was the case in
this patient that the lesion proved to
be an umbrella rent allowance or coma
would you comment dr. Martin on your
approach to this problem is the pkt
difficult problem
the fixation of the mass to the voltage
just report on preclude local excision
as a means of treating this is the
definitive surgical procedures unless we
are quite radical approach the spread of
a axilla again means we must be more
radical ivory the only way we can post
their surgically other than contain a
biopsy would be to do a fourth-quarter
education which isn't really a run of
mutilating operation for a small child a
face with her 55 more years as going
around with the fourth quarter educated
now I would use the pre-med or biopsy
only and indeed other modalities such as
either radiation or chemotherapy as far
as the defendant management I believe
the only alteration we should do with
the ax for emancipation that as a
security type of physique I'm glad to
hear you say that because I think 2i is
possible even in this particular
presentation by such radical surgery but
i'd like to have start to test if he
feels is any place from radiation
therapy in the management of this
particular patient well as dr. Martin
has indicated this is indeed a very
difficult problem irradiation at high
dose especially in when combined with
chemotherapy has resulted in marks
progression of some of these are leaders
but when the disease can be removed
surgically lest there be local
recurrence and ones not assured total
eradication of all cells in this
particular region it might be as well to
do such a radical procedure as dr.
Martin is indicated in other areas such
as soon as apparent when total surgical
extirpation is usually not possible the
radical high-dose radiation when
combined with chemotherapy has a need
resulted in the survival implantation
works of mercy would you come in on the
shaming influential primary location of
the umbrella tomorrow
hormone prognosis or possibly even
treatment embryonal rhabdomyosarcoma may
arise from soft parts of the head and
neck the genitourinary tract the
extremities or the retroperitoneal areas
the prognosis is somewhat better when
the origin of the tumor is in the head
and neck area chemotherapy of choice for
embryonal rhabdomyosarcoma is
actinomyces and B cyclocross med and
vincristine also has some beneficial
effect this tumor invade the bone marrow
and therefore marrow examination needs
to be carried out before the
chemotherapy is selected and in this
particular instance may I ask assuming
that a full-court amputation were done
would you recommend in the
post-operative period that any you know
so-called suppressive team authority be
administered that this is a leading
question but i'd be interested in your
thoughts on the mountain well that the
frequency with which this tumor
metastasize is widely including the
equation the bone marrow I think it's
worthwhile to consider a so-called
prophylactic chemotherapy and in this
condition give repeated courses of
actomyosin date or perhaps I think this
is a good situation to use combined
chemotherapy it's been some interest in
accidental my should be together we've
been Christine and we've given accent of
mice and be together with psycho crosman
in repeated courses in an effort to
obtain you earlier years alone in order
to continuously suppress this too much
pleasure certainly along with the x-ray
therapy and surgery doc martens your
great as I yeah if you have any other
comment I think I would agree with that
one particular child with a
rhabdomyosarcoma to orbit which we see
the slide on was the test is the local
area
radical operation exhilarating the
Corbett primary causes of tissues the
metastatic lesions were removed but only
local removal and Metallica was deep
radiation to the mesh and the road
disappeared completely it's only been 19
months since the procedure we still feel
that the prognosis is poor but such a
hopeful of currents they should feel as
though it's not entirely hopeless
disease I think many of us have the
impression that's possibly in Bryan
already know myself home erosion in the
head in that area may be a little more
responsive to radiation therapy and such
too much arrives in elsewhere and may
have a little better prognosis although
this is very difficult to prove
statistically would you even see how to
comment on that dr. Kemp do you think
they have a somewhat better prognosis I
think that I agree that he gets built to
analyze it particularly the patient
numbers are small but ones impression is
officially can be true or any other
comments many of you would care to make
about this case it's not in some right
then I think we have presented three
fairly typical cases of solid malignant
tumors in childhood and their treatment
has been mostly be discussed by my panel
members feel I think it is worthwhile to
note that current practice favors that
combines therapeutic approach in which
the capabilities of several medical
disciplines surgeries radiation therapy
and chemotherapy may be and frequently
all utilized in the manage modeling the
total pay of these patients childhood
cancer is happily not common but does
rank is the second most frequent cause
of death and children past the neonatal
period with early diagnosis and was
skilled and dedicated treatment however
a favorable outcome may be anticipated
in its a substantial number of these
patients
this program Children's Cancer current
album was produced by the American
radium society during a 50th annual
meeting miami beach florida April 1968
you